on va prendre dans une bulle rentre dans
une bulle
vous pouvez fermer la topore
allez-y bonjour monsieur ça va bien je
suis avec des potes c'est rien c'est la
télé c'est magouille et compagnie
tout va bien voilà donc tu vas tu vois
entrer
et voilà et vous de sautez et vous
essayez de tout faire tomber dessus
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà fini allez casse-toi dis
contre Verdez
[Musique]
ce fou rire faites attention derrière
non pas du tout merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas ça va toi tu as mal quoi
donc là donc là on va voir
un combat on va faire deux demi-finale
avec un garçon si tu veux jouer avec
Gilles
très fort
en sortie
j'ai été éliminé ça va
ranger bravo
[Applaudissements]
oh mon dieu a gagné
j'arrive pas à sortir Raymond Verdun
elle est où ma Gégé je suis désolé ah
merde
ça va ma Gégé
[Musique]
tu nous racontes pas ta vie tout à
l'heure merci c'est bon là ok je suis en
émission là tu as gagné
tout à l'heure là je suis en émission ok
elle nous raconte sa vie là je suis
revenu
allez vas-y vas-y ça va te jette
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les mecs ça va jouer en deux manches ok
dimanche
vous y allez à fond voilà si il y en a
un qui doit périr il périra
mais qu'il périsse dans le calme et la
sérénité d'accord
ça va toi très bien fait plaisir de te
voir ça fait un très bon si ça c'est
j'ai regardé l'émission c'était
incroyable
j'étais dans la rue je regardais ça
franchement ces gens sont formidables
franchement c'est vrai les fous de voir
des gens comme ça sur l'actualité
bon vous êtes prêts c'est pour vous
laisser un petit peu
réfléchir à la vie attention c'est parti
[Musique]
vas-y vas-y allez bon c'est bon on
dirait Guillaume oh bravo
ça va ça va ça va bien
[Applaudissements]
tranquille
doucement au début et après tu dois le
défoncer défoncer
doucement au début et si tu dois le
défoncer
moi alors je devais faire le jeu je vais
voir parce que
moi je te respecte je suis un expertise
de haut niveau je suis un tournoi demain
tu vois
j'ai pas envie de dire je me suis blessé
au poignet là tout à l'heure
spectateurs les chéris vous allez voir
c'est la grande finale Raymond bravo je
voudrais qu'on applaudissait
bravo mon chéri c'est bien pour ça que
bah pour ça que tu étais vraiment mon
frère Mokhtar même
il fait le ramadan de ne pas tout c'est
parti
c'est bon
[Musique]
on peut y aller
[Applaudissements]
attendez on va la refaire on va la
refaire on va la refaire on va la
refaire
je voudrais voir mon tél contre Mokhtar
la deuxième elle est vraiment
il se reposer il a quand même une
émission à faire
bouge pas
[Musique]
laisse-le pour l'instant vas-y
laisse-le bouger pour l'instant bouge
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
il faut que tu sautes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
attention mon frère
attends attends attends
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attends
c'est tout ce qu'on te demande
attention Alexandre guerrier c'était son
anniversaire ah d'accord le reste je
m'en fous OK
non non non
[Musique]
tu les as tous défoncés
Guillaume
mon chéri attention fais attention aux
autres vous je m'en fous fais attention
aux gens qui travaillent ok il y a des
gens qui travaillent j'aurais pas
comblée un cadreur
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que tu peux l'attaquer toi
maintenant maintenant
c'est bon
c'est que tu fasses une dernière mais
vraiment en crash test vas-y je pense
que tu peux en faire une dernière en
crash test tu pars de là-bas tu pars de
là-bas
c'est bon allez on lève la boule là
enlève la boule là c'est bon tu as très
bien joué
exceptionnel chérie on va à Castaldi tu
veux pas faire ça pas le coup
Castaldi a mal au cou
et bravo bravo à Gilles Géraldine à
Bernard et et les autres d'être là parce
que c'est important que vous soyez
présent